[Musique]
en sarre
non
dan care email
kelman
[Musique]
et
m
yanga mbiwa
et fils ben day day
c'est demain c'est
[Musique]
inhabitée
il fit ce père
lol
c
le
il me faut
je suis hélas
et mm e funny people quand mignon
laurent mignon bien
mais
ça m
qui
ce qui sauve ma came chagny molsheim
chan
d
m
non
[Musique]
c
oui
un autre
non
sauf le thème les délits
m
et
mais enfin
je n'étais
oh
kim est pêché ce qu'il me tarde
qu'il me fallait battre amiens
g
m
ça m'étonne que mia
ce pyromane
quelques chalets
ébauche année
chat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci pour votre écoute
attentive
voilà je suis vraiment super contente
d'être ici ce soir je suis je suis très
fier de pouvoir faire partie de ce panel
de de gens pour ce tedx le way of life
alors way of life moi j'en ai qu'une
seule de façon de vivre que j'ai envie
de partager avec vous aujourd'hui c'est
celle d'essayer de vivre de sa musique
en belgique et donc c'est par rapport à
ça que je vais vous raconter une petite
histoire aujourd'hui
alors j'ai pas trop trop l'habitude de
parler devant un public d'universitaires
donc je vais essayer de pas dire trop de
bêtises
par contre avec son fjord ça fait à peu
près deux ans qu'on a la chance de
participer aux tournées des jeunesses
musicales
donc c'est à dire qu'avec avec le gros
parce que je suis donc la chanteuse un
groupe on se déplace dans les écoles
secondaires et on va jouer devant un
public âgé de après 12 à 18 ans et c'est
une expérience qui est super
enrichissante vraiment est aussi assez
interpellante parce que pendant notre
spectacle ya toujours un petit moment on
leur donne la possibilité de nous poser
toutes leurs questions et après vraiment
des dizaines de spectacles dans pleins
d'écoles différentes
je me suis enfin on s'est rendu compte
que c'était souvent les mêmes questions
qui revenait en fait finalement à savoir
principalement vous gagnez combien avec
le projet et vous avez combien de
followers combien d'abonnés est ce que
vous êtes reconnu quoi alors je
comprends tout à fait qu'ils nous posent
ces questions là parce que ça fait
partie de leur réalité
mais n'empêche que voir à quel point ces
questions avaient leur importante pour
eux m'a quand même vachement surpris et
quelque part je me disais c'est fou que
le résultat finalement ce qu'on gagne
la performance de ce qu'on gagne avec
tout ça soit tellement importante pour
eux parce que quelque part je pense que
voilà je parle en mon nom mais je pense
que je parle au nom de plein d'artistes
en belgique et partout dans le monde
si on avait envie de gagner plein de
thunes on ferait un autre métier et puis
aussi quand on se lance comme ça dans la
musique faut accepter de jouer devant un
public qui est parfois 20 au début
inexistant ou qui n'est pas forcément là
pour nous faut accepter aussi qu'ils
allaient qu'il ya des mois qu'ils sont
enfin là il ya une instabilité quoi on
gagne pas la même chose chaque mois et
quand même une instabilité financière
et puis surtout c'est un métier dans
lequel on ferme pas la porte du bureau à
la fin de la journée
donc c'est très difficile de se mettre
sur off en fait on est tellement il ya
tellement de on se donne tellement
personnellement parfois c'est difficile
de faire la part des choses entre sa vie
privée sa vie professionnelle
alors vous allez me demander avec tout
ça pourquoi pourquoi tu as choisi ce
métier je crois qu'à un moment donné de
ma vie j'ai juste eu un espèce de
feeling une intuition que c'était
peut-être voilà quelque part une une
activité dans laquelle j'avais pouvoir
m'épanouir et en fait j'ai écrit mes
premiers morceaux quand j'avais à peu
près 16 17 ans j'étais en école fin
avant secondaire et je me suis direct
dit j'aime bien faire ce à quoi s'est
épanoui je kiffe vraiment j'aime bien
écrire des morceaux et ça je me disais
ça aura une place dans ma vie
certainement plus tard mais je savais
pas encore très bien sous quelle forme
après j'ai suivi des études de
communication et de journalisme des
études vraiment super intéressante qui
m'ont appris plein de choses qui m'ont
permis de voyager et d'avoir un certain
regard sur le monde et puis à la fin de
mes études je me suis un petit peu
retrouvé face à un dilemme d'une part
j'avais la possibilité de postuler pour
un emploi à temps plein vachement stable
là où j'avais réalisé mon stage un
acteur j'avais toujours dans un coin de
ma tête ce projet de musique que j'avais
envie de développer et je me disais si
je me mets dans un job à temps plein je
ris al soir après le boulot je serai
crever finalement je sais ça mènera à
rien quoi j'avais envie de me mettre à
fond dedans et donc à ce moment là j'ai
pas forcément suivi les conseils qu'on
me donne et je me suis dit ok je me
donne six mois pour faire de la musique
exclusivement fin avec un petit boulot à
côté quand même pour
gagner un peu d'argent mais vraiment je
mettrai toute mon énergie dans la
musique et donc je me disais six mois
après je me suis rendu compte au bout de
ces six mois que cette histoire de six
mois c'était complètement ridicule en
fait parce que au bout de six mois on
était vraiment tout début du processus
du cheminement du groupe et la salle et
nous prendre bien plus de temps que ça
pour construire un truc mais ça a quand
même suffi pour que je m'en rende compte
que j'aimais vraiment bien ce que je
faisais que ça m'épanouissais que
j'étais bien au quotidien quoi et donc
je me suis dit ok je continue la dent
j'ai envie de continuer et là ça fait à
peu près trois ans que je fais de la
musique et que et que voilà j'en ai fait
ma priorité et je regrette absolument
pas parce que même s'il ya des hauts et
des bats pas tous les jours facile que
c'est clair qu'il ya des jours où on
croit que plus nuls et qu'on est trop
nul et que ça mènera à rien et quand
même des jours et surtout des moments et
surtout sur scène quand on partage avec
le public on se dit waow mais en fait
c'est exactement ça que j'ai envie de
faire et est donc quand les camps les
jeunes en jeunesse musicale me pose ces
questions de savoir ray mais vous gagnez
combien ce que vous êtes connus j'ai
envie de leur dire égard si vous avez un
projet qui vous tient à coeur qui est
pas forcément dans la norme qui est pas
forcément voilà le chemin le plus
classique on pourra vous conseiller
mais un truc que vous avez envie de
faire ne fait pas trop attention aux
résultats ne fait pas trop attention est
ce que ça va vous rapporter de l'argent
ça va vous rendre connu parce que sinon
ça va vous mettre une pression de dingue
en fait et vous allez avoir peur de vous
planter et vous aurez plus rien faire du
tout quoi voilà assez assez parlé je
vais vous faire un autre morceau de sony
forte qui s'appelle et lights où l'avait
déjà entendu en fait c'est le petit
jingle qui passe entre chaque
intervenant
et pour la petite histoire j'ai encore
parlé un petit peu ce morceau je les
écris j'étais chez mes parents pendant
le week-end et j'étais devant la télé et
mes parents dormaient déjà et puis un
coup j'ai cette mélodie qui a commencé à
me rentrer dans la tête et
je me suis dit j'ai envie de composer un
morceau par contre ma maison est pas
super bien isolée donc j'ai dû aller
mettre dans la salle de bain pour être
sûr que je réveille personnes et pour
pouvoir chanter aussi fort que je
voulais voilà light
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
où
et de kenny rogers les camps
voyez chez dans l'axé avec eux suite à
une folle
et bien enfants
bb barnard sauveteurs
c'est grave
l'île de montréal
oh
e
plus qu'un vieux monsieur mois les
displaced fuel a mal aux bruits de
telles sommes
d'ici là
[Musique]
était-ce classifiés
oh ça soit 2,6
café
les monnaies
ça
les deux sens
[Musique]
benzerga
chimie fine espèce est brillant
c'est vrai mais une
qu'un vieux monsieur en l'espèce est
fier
open fit d'elle ça
aucun d'eux d'ici là
plus vieux
oh ça
sylla
quelques
mickey
m
été signalé
can you we can you hear me comme kelly
gc
campioli d'espèces vieux
pas de fuite
on
m
merci
[Musique]